Chat.
Ich bin nicht zufrieden mit dem Chat.
Ich hab mir das die letzten Streams jetzt angeguckt.
Und es wurde deutlich mehr Kekwe als Lulwe verwendet.
Ich seh mich fast gezwungen Kekwe zu sperren.
Dabei wissen wir alle, dass Lulwe das einzig wahre Lachemote ist.
Also wer ernsthaft meint, dass Kekwe mit Lulwe mithalten kann, der soll sich löschen.
Beste, Lulwe sehr viel größer als Kekwe.
Wer ist eigentlich der Typ im Lulwe-Emote, der gleiche wie im Lul-Emote.
Genauso wie im LUL-Emote und im Lul-3D-Emote.
Das ist TotalBiscuit, das war mal ein Youtuber, ich weiß nicht, ob er je gestreamt hat.
Leider lebt er nicht mehr.
Nicht G-Bait, ich wäre froh, wenn es G-Bait wäre.
Es ist kein G-Bait.
Leider lebt TotalBiscuit nicht mehr.
Der war ungefähr mal im Alter.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann ist der gestorben?
Wie alt war der noch?
33 Leute.
Der hatte seltene Krebserkrankungen für dieses Alter und ist mit 33 gestorben.
Das war einer der ersten, die ich mitgekriegt habe, die in meinem Alter den Löffel abgegeben
haben.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, Max langsam wird es eng.
Dann kam Internet-Hulk noch, der Overwatch-Spieler, dann kam erst letztens InControl dabei, jetzt
irgendwie ein paar Streamer, die selbstwortbegangen haben, Alter was ist hier los?
Ich habe langsam Gedanken, dass ich die nächsten 10 Jahre nicht mehr überlebe.
Streamer sind die neue Risikogruppe, wie es aussieht.
Streamer und Pro-Gamer, wobei ich bin ja kein Pro-Gamer, also trifft es mich schon mal nicht.
Es ist echt heftig, wie viele einigermaßen bekannte Leute im Internet in den letzten
Jahren den Löffel abgegeben haben.
Das ist hart.
Da habe ich mich auch teilweise echt mitgenommen.
Gibt es eigentlich was Neues?
Reddit Dr.
Disrespect.
Gibt es eigentlich was Neues zum Dr.
Disrespect-Bun?
Gibt es da irgendetwas Neues?
Was ist da los?
Gibt nichts Neues oder?
Zwei Wochen ist schon her.
Twitter, Doktor, gibt es da jetzt irgendetwas Neues?
Nein.
Ja ok, das ist Blödsinn, das ist Schwachsinn, dass der selbst nicht darüber informiert
wurde.
Das ist irgendein Move, ich weiß nicht genau warum, wahrscheinlich was die aktuelle Situation
so hergibt.
Aber da gibt es nichts Neues?
Was ist da los?
Warum nicht?
Sacked.
Was sagst du dazu, sagt der, also der Umut fragt mich gerade, was sagst du dazu, dass
wir demnächst 40TB Tapes haben werden für die LTO-Bänder?
Ja was soll ich dazu sagen, es ist halt Band, also Band ist jetzt ja nicht mehr so das trendige
Medium 2020.
2020, wenn man sich überlegt, es ist jetzt über 50 Jahre her, dass, ich weiß es gibt
Zweifler, ja, also ich weiß es gibt Leute, die glauben das immer noch nicht, ja, aber
es ist jetzt über 50 Jahre her, dass sie auf Mut gelandet sind, also wir jetzt mal so
für die Menschheit gesprochen, ja, über 50 Jahre her, kann man sich gerade vorstellen,
Lul, Wahnsinn.
Und hätte mal, hätte den Amis mal einer erzählt, 1970, dass die 2020 mit den Russen
ins Weltall fliegen, die hätten, die hätten sich weggekackt.
Die haben gedacht, ne, auf gar keinen Fall, kann nicht sein, aber die Amis fliegen mit
den Russen ins Weltall, ok, jetzt haben sie SpaceX und vielleicht können sie aber selbst
wieder fliegen, Selfmade Ice, 3 Monate, dankeschön, excellent Subscription, huge.
Ähm, ja schon heftig, ne, das hätten die im Leben nicht geglaubt.
Und die Leute, die Leute 1970 auch nicht, 1970 hätten die das auch nicht geglaubt, 1970
die Leute hier so zur Mondlandung, die Leute haben alle gedacht im Kopf so 2020, Alter,
das sind wir, das sind wir auf Mars, haben irgendwie Jupiter-Raumstationen oder fragt
mich nicht, alle möglichen abgedrehten Sachen, ja, und wir sind nicht auf dem Mars, wir haben
die Jupiter-Raumstationen, wir haben eigentlich, was das angeht, kaum Progress gemacht, dafür
haben wir andere Probleme, ja, zum Beispiel werden heutzutage wieder Leute enthauptet,
weil sie ungläubig sind, das war 1970, war das besser, also es war, früher, gab manche
Sachen, die waren früher tatsächlich nicht, nicht vorhanden, ja, und also wir haben uns
in manchen Sachen schon ein bisschen zurückentwickelt, so die letzten 50 Jahre, ja, aber hätte den
diesmal einer erzählt, dass sie mit den Russen mitfliegen, 50 Jahre später, das hätte auch
keiner geglaubt.
Hatten die beiden, hatten das eine gute Frage, hatten die bei der Mondlandung bereits die
benötigten Scrum Masters, die hatten die Vorgänger davon, bei der, beim, bei dem damaligen
Mondprogramm, also beim ganzen Space-Programm von der NASA damals, viele aktuelle Projektmanagement-Methoden
da entwickelt, unter anderem Gantt-Diagramme, wer diese hässlichen Sachen nicht kennt,
Ausgeburt des Teufels, falls man an sowas glaubt, dann hat der auf jeden Fall Gantt-Diagramme
erfunden, das ist bei der, wurde bei der NASA während dem Apollo-Programm entwickelt,
nur, dass ich jetzt keinen Bullshit erzähle, ich glaube, ich glaube ich zumindest, ich,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja und damals hatten sie noch kein Elektron, damals hatten sie Rechenleistung,
wie auf einem, ein Cent China-Taschenrechner, CPU heute, so, nur für den gleich da, stimmt
ja nicht, ich bin ja schon da, was, oder, was sagen euch, was sagen euch die aktuellen
GitHub Trends, zeig mal her, This Week, Hacking Tool, ah nee, das war also, Backstage, juckt
mich nicht, Skywater, juckt mich auch nicht, Tsunami Scanner, juckt mich in Deutschland
auch nicht, Deep Learning auch nicht, Rich auch nicht, was, White, Native, WebDev, wie
viele Build Tools gibt es eigentlich für JavaScript, es vergeht ja keine Woche, wo
nicht irgendeine neue Build Tool rauskommt, was haben wir jetzt so alles, Webpack und 50
Webpack Alternativen, jetzt haben wir wohl noch White, ok, alles klar, Chat, Chat, das
kann nicht sein, der Chat ist bei mir auf Twitch gerade, Chira-Clone, ja das hat, das
hat natürlich noch gefehlt, also die Bullshit-Kombination schlechthin, die muss natürlich noch übertroffen
werden, man hat sich gedacht, ok, Java-Backend mit irgendeinem zusammengefuddelten jQuery-Frontend
ist noch nicht schlimm genug, also macht man einen JavaScript-Backend mit Angular-Frontend,
also wenn man sich denkt, es kann kaum noch schlimmer kommen, kommt irgendein GitHub-Typ
um die Ecke und macht einen Chira-Clone in Angular, Ultimate Go, aha, Responsively App,
was ist das, ein modifizierter Browser für, oh das sieht tatsächlich ganz praktisch aus,
das Book mag ich mir mal, das macht einen echt praktischen Eindruck, Elsa sagt, wären
die bei der Mondlandung mit Elektron geflogen, wären die Rakete doppelt so groß gewesen
für all den RAM, ja in SpaceX ist ja angeblich die Frontend, das Frontend auf den Monitor,
Watch-Screen, das da, das da, das ist angeblich Elektron, Javascript, ok weiß ich nicht ob
es Elektron ist, aber es ist angeblich Javascript, das ist alles Javascript Zeug, aber sie haben
angeblich für alles noch Knöpfe, was ich auch verstehen kann, weil man will ja nicht,
dass der Kram nicht funktioniert, wenn es drauf ankommt, heute fliegen wir mit Javascript
zum Mond, jetzt ist ja auch kein Wunder, dass die 50 Jahre gebraucht haben, also vor 50
Jahren haben CPUs ausgereicht, die schlechter sind als in den billigsten Schielertaschenrechner,
ohne Javascript und jetzt mit Javascript braucht man halt 50 Jahre CPU Entwicklung und Rechner
Entwicklung, dass man überhaupt noch wieder auf den Mond fliegen kann, der Kram der läuft
halt jetzt erst, irgendwie ist da Any, Fast Simple Clean Video Downloader, oh das klingt
ja tatsächlich ganz interessant, was ist das, sieht das Logo, sieht fast aus wie von Visual
Studio, guck mal, die werden doch verklagt, seht ihr das, das Visual Studio Logo und das
Any Logo, das ist schon sehr ähnlich, also was macht das, Fast Simple Clean Video Downloader,
ich soll FFmpeg zusätzlich installieren, warum, ach guck mal, das gibt es für Archlinux
im Userreport, das installieren wir uns jetzt mal, das muss ich mal ausprobieren, weil YouTube
DL ist ganz nett, aber so ein bisschen alternative schaden ja nichts, was, Any heißt das, Wenny,
Any, hier eins, exellent, probieren wir mal aus, naja, mach hin, probieren wir mal aus,
mal gucken ob das taugt, so, dann gehen wir mal auf YouTube und gucken ob der Max ein
neues Video veröffentlicht hat, und dann laden wir das runter, was ist das beste was
du je im Trending Tab von GitHub gefunden hast, boah, das weiß ich jetzt aus dem Kopf
nicht, aber was ich richtig cool fand in letzter Zeit war die Mac OS vm, fertig als
Skript, oh was macht der denn jetzt, aber da kompidiert er erstmal 3 Stunden irgendwelche
Go Dependencies oder sowas, naja gut, soll er mal machen, guck mal, was ist denn sonst
auch schönes am Trenden, übrigens was mir GitHub letztens empfohlen hat ist das hier,
how to create a CSGO Cheating Program auf Chinesisch, also wer schon immer mal in Chinesisch
lernen wollte, wie er ein CSGO cheat programmiert, das sei der richtig, was ist das eigentlich
für Fahrstuhlmusik, ey gut, es ist Lunchtime Jazz, hier machen wir ein bisschen was anderes
gerade hier, so, du schaust morgens auch immer erst dieses Trending Tab, das ist nicht verkehrt,
das ist echt interessant was da teilweise auf GitHub drinne ist, ich mein das ist auch
richtig cool, wenn man einfach mal sehen will wie sieht seine App aus auf unterschiedlichen
Geräten ist das richtig praktisch, man kann das auch mit Chrome machen, Lunchtime Jazz
oder Lunchtime JS, ja lieber Jazz, bald hören wir Merkel, Lofi, sowas, ok mich wundert
fast nichts mehr, so ist installiert Rehash, Rehash, das ist dann die Kommandos, so wie
ist das Any, wir geben einen Download Ordner, Any und jetzt downloaden wir mal mein Video,
excellent, Copy Image, ah muss man Quote, logisch, lull, und Funkt, ey, ok ob das jetzt
besser ist als der YouTube Downloader sei mal dahingestellt, ich mein der macht genau
das gleiche, er lädt auf jeden Fall schonmal die maximale Quality Version runter, nicht
sonderlich schnell, er wird auch immer langsamer, YouTube DL, jetzt gucken wir mal auf GitHub
wie das mit YouTube DL, ist das Python oder welcher Sprache ist YouTube DL programmiert,
ah ja nur 70.000 Sterne, easy, gibt es Parameter für Qualität, das probieren wir mal aus,
ja das ist Python, Gedulds, Leute ich hab letztens vor ein paar Tagen auf der Arbeit
zum ersten Mal Gibi Byte verwendet, Gibi Byte und irgendwie hat es die Leute verwirrt, es
ist ja auch ganz schön fail wenn man sich das mal überlegt, also die Geschichte dahinter
ist schon irgendwie kein Wunder, dass sich das nicht durchsetzt, ursprünglich gab es
diesen Kram gar nicht, ursprünglich haben sie sich gar nicht mit so komischen Bullshit,
eigentlich ist es ganz sinnvoll, ursprünglich haben sie sich gar nicht mit so komischen Abkürzungen
abgegeben, sondern die haben einfach gesagt Gigabyte oder naja ursprünglich haben sie
eher Kilo Byte gesagt, weil Gigabyte war ja noch damals nicht, Gibi Byte, so und als
erstes war Kilo Byte am Start und dann hat man gedacht, okay reicht ja eigentlich auch,
aber das Problem war ja, denn Kilo Byte war 1024, was ja nicht dem Wort Kilo entspricht,
also Kilo ist ja 1000 und nicht 1024, allerdings hat sich das in der IT, in der Informatik
halt eingebürgert, weil es halt immer 2 hoch irgendwas ist, also 2, 4, 8, 16, 32, 64,
16, 128, 256, 512, 1024, 2048, 4096, wer kommt weiter aus dem Kopf, wer kommt weiter aus
dem Kopf, 8100 irgendetwas, ja 8192, aber das kann ich nicht mehr aus dem Kopf, und was
kommt danach, 8100 mal 2, ah 16384, ahja alles klar, so und dann kamen irgendwelche Big Brain
Leute auf die Idee und haben gesagt, ah wir brauchen da eine andere Einheit für und jetzt
hat man halt Kilo Byte umfunktioniert, also sprich früher war Kilo Byte eigentlich IT
mäßig immer 1024, allerdings wurde Kilo falsch verwendet, deswegen hat man jetzt gesagt,
ne wir verwenden Kilo jetzt richtig, nämlich 1000 und schaffen dafür eine neue Einheit
KiByte, nur das Problem ist kaum einer verwendet die, kaum einer verwendet den Kram, so hat
das Video downloaden jetzt eigentlich funktioniert, ne es lädt noch runter, naja zumindest eigentlich
das ist so ein typischer Fall von, eigentlich ist es gut, praktisch wurde es nicht wirklich
angenommen, und irgend einer hat gerade gesagt, wird das nicht in der Cloud alles so gerechnet,
doch zum größten Teil schon, zumindest die Status Ausgaben vieler Tools, deswegen habe
ich es auch verwendet, ich habe Kubernetes Cluster Ressourcen zusammengesucht und die
sind in KiByte oder in, jetzt haltet euch mal fest, die Kubernetes Jungs haben auch
ein bisschen den Arsch offen was Einheiten angeht, Kubernetes Millie CPU Cores, oder
ne wie ist das Millie, Millie Core, Millie Cores, oder ne war halt, ne Millie CPU hieß
das, Millie CPU, die sind ganz, ganz wirr, ganz wirr, ich find's jetzt gar nicht, ja
also es ist nicht so ganz klar immer, aber ich hab ja Educational im Tag, da muss ich
manchmal auch ein bisschen Big Brain Sachen erzählen, moin Foggets, oder ist es Foggets,
das ist bestimmt Französisch, Foggets, ne, wobei wenn es Französisch wäre es VG, oder
so, so, Moment, Moment, wo bin ich jetzt hier stehen geblieben, Trends, ich wollte gerade
noch mal fertig gucken, haben die Trends doch gar nicht fertig geguckt, zwar ich hab mal
auf die Monats Trends, schauen was da drin steht, aber das, ich hab das, wir probieren
das jetzt, wir laden das gleiche noch mal mit YouTube DL runter, gucken was schneller
ist, das kommt mir Hardcore langsam vor, gerade der Download von dem YouTube Video,
das beim Download sind das Gibi Byte oder Gigabyte, also das sind Mibi Byte, also 1024,
also mit 1024 gerechnet in dem Fall, Mibi, das ist ganz, das ist schon ziemlich pipäger,
also 1024, 1024, 1024 mal 1024 Bytes, so, ok, jetzt machen wir das ganze mit YouTube
DL, mal ausprobieren was da schneller ist, zuerst mal gucken ob das Video jetzt funktioniert,
hat das jetzt runtergeladen, als Battlefield noch Hype war, ok, kann er das noch abspiele,
oh, ich hab, wat, ich hab kein VLC drauf, warum hab ich denn kein VLC drauf, null, na
gut, normalerweise brauch ich in der VM kein VLC, jetzt haben wir auch ein VLC drauf,
das ist wieder ein Grund dafür warum ich immer noch der Meinung, Pacman und die ganzen User
Repos sind die, es sind nicht Mibi, es sind Maybe, Moment, ja stimmt es könnten auch Bits
gewesen sein, es könnten auch Bits gewesen sein, allerdings ist das B groß, also sind
das in dem Fall Bytes, also wenn sie es ganz richtig gemacht haben, sind das, warte was,
sind das Mibi, Maybe Bytes oder Mibi Bytes, Mibi, Mibi Bytes, also kein Mibi Bytes, ja
was denn jetzt, Mibi Bytes ist richtig, meine Güte, das ist ja so ppeger, also das müsste
in dem Fall müssten es tatsächlich Mibi Bytes pro Sekunde gewesen sein, achso VLC,
kann man das jetzt abspielen, aha, ok, ja dann, alles klar, gut, also das funktioniert,
so und jetzt gucken wir uns das ganze mit youtube.dl nochmal an, esasany, youtube.dl, das ist
viel schneller oder, oder kommt mir das nur schneller vor, das schwankt wie Sau, die Anzeige
ist ziemlich fail, aber mir kommt es eine ganze Ecke schneller vor, ja viel schneller,
guck mal wie lang das jetzt in Go gerade runter geladen hat, exzellent, vielleicht kann youtube.dl
von mehreren Quellen laden oder so, ah da sieht baro kennt sich aus, ja viel schneller,
viel schneller ist das, vielleicht kann man auch angeben, das probieren wir gleich mal
aus, wir gucken mal ob es das gleiche ist, aber ich denke mal es ist die gleiche Datei,
oh jetzt Merch da, ah ne, es ist, wir können mal gucken, md5 zoom drüber, md5 zoom da drüber,
und md5 zoom, na gut ob die stimmt weiß ich nicht, ja guckt exzakt die gleiche Datei,
also viel, viel schneller, wir gucken mal ob das, ich meine es ist die gleiche Datei,
es muss auch die gleichen Probleme beim abspielen haben, ah ne jetzt, hä moment, warum hat
das, warum hat das beim abspielen keine Probleme jetzt, ah hat es wieder nicht, ok, vlc, just
vlc things, der übrigens übelst rumleckt, ah ne, so und warum soll ich das jetzt verwenden
gegenüber youtube.dl, ah ne, download, und warum, similar project youtube.dl, was ist
der vorteil hier von jetzt, ok, eh, warum weiß ich nicht so genau, wegen dem profilbild
der entwickler, wieso, was haben die für ein profilbild, ah verstehe, ja allein schon
aus dem grund, ne, hm, es muss, default 10, ok warum das jetzt deutlich langsamer war
als youtube.dl leuchtet mir nicht ein, aber wir löschen das mal auf jeden fall wieder,
weil das verbraucht viel zu viel, speicherplatz, exellent, so, was trendet denn sonst noch
schönes, youtube.dl kann auch mehr als youtube, ja, ja, eh youtube.dl kann, also saumäßig
viel, wahrscheinlich sogar die ganzen sternchen hub seiten, ok juck mich nicht, so viele
java zeugs, eh, was ist da los, musik ist ein bisschen laut oder passt, ne, die chinesen
und java wieder, ja, so viel, java, die chinesen machen nur in sachen java, guckt euch an
hier, der titel ist ja mal so geil, ehm, ja, der titel ist keq vs the service, der grund
ist, ich hab mir überlegt, ob wir nicht mal, das war aber nicht heute, nur mal von der
idee her, ehm, ich hab mir überlegt als sachen, die wir mal im stream machen können, dass
wir auch was überschaubares haben, was man, eh, da wollte ich euch mal fragen was ihr
dazu sagt, dass wir was überschaubares haben, was man in 1, 2, maximal 3 streams machen
kann, also was ich gerne, was ich gerne mal machen würde, weil ich weiß, dass mittlerweile
hier viele zugucken, einmal welche, die sich ein bisschen fürs programmieren interessieren,
andere, die sich für linux sachen interessieren, andere, die sich für, sag mal, webentwicklungszeug
interessieren, andere für netzwerkgeschichten, also alles mögliche, ja, ehm, ich hab mir
überlegt, ob wir keq vs the service programmieren, was total simpel wird, wir machen mit ffmpeg,
wir nehmen uns irgendein recitas video, also irgendein, irgendein, 2 minuten, das original,
das, keine ahnung, wir nehmen uns das original recitas video, und dann machen wir mit ffmpeg
da draus jede sekunde nen screenshot, aus dem video, die speichern wir, und dann programmieren
wir ne ganz, ganz, wirklich simpelste webanwendung, die, eh, quasi random keqw bilder ausliefert,
also irgendwie, du rufst die url auf, und es kommt einfach ein, ein bild aus, ein thumbnail
aus diesem, diesem, gesamten video, also der sinn der anwendung ist jetzt erstmal egal,
zumindest was ich vor hab, erstens, dass wir ne simple webanwendung programmieren, und
uns dann angucken, wie man die schön deployen und hosten kann, und während wir das entwickeln,
machen wir es auch ganz ordentlich mit git und commits und alle möglichen, sodass wir
mal so ein sehr überschaubares beispielprojekt haben, ehm, was man in 1-2 streams machen
kann, kannst du nicht gesichtserkennung machen und klippen, bestimmt, bestimmt, bestimmt,
aber das wird mir zu advanced, custom, ehm, custom, custom keqw, es wären dann auch easter
egg top, ja, das ist richtig gut, also hier, keqw as a service, ja hauptsache es, es muss
immer, es muss immer, wir können uns auch noch in jankins oder in github actions, oder
so installieren, natürlich wir machen git, github actions, fürs deployen, hosten, und
programmieren machen wir wir können sogar noch reverse proxy oder so machen für
alternifizierung
dass man für manche keck wies
hallo 1 2 3 als passwort eingeben muss
Irgendwas es geht nicht so sehr und dann noch eine api ssl ja klar ja klar ssl ssl ssl muss auch sein
richtig gute idee genau dass wir mal das in den 1 2 stream angucken
kopane das trendet wieder
ich hatte wieder wie nennt man das wenn man außerirdische trifft begegnung der
dritten art oder so wie sagt man dazu ja ich glaube glaub schon da wenn man
wenn man außerirdische trifft so und ich hatte heute auch wieder eine begegnung
der der dritten art und zwar mal wieder mit project managern auf der arbeit
was sind denn die ersten zwei arten ja die menschheit und der twitch chat
mehr gibt es ja nicht also eine keck wie begegnung ja es ist so wir zeige ich euch ist
ich so wir also bei uns auf der arbeit haben sie sich jetzt folgendes ausgedacht
ich muss mich jetzt gerade mal ein bisschen bisschen renten wieder dazu
machen wir jetzt mal kurz hier ein dance paper an das passt dann ganz gut was
heißt passt gut passt passt eigentlich gar nicht aber bewegt sich was also ich
wusste ich wusste jetzt mal was wollen captain peng der twitch chat ist der
product owner das stakeholder sozusagen was ja wenn man da jetzt modern ist so
und auch noch ein französischer paper anstamm stand übrigens ich habe jetzt
habe ich jetzt hate symbol ist es jetzt ist offiziell eingetragen das hassymbol
jetzt genauso wie genauso wie moment genauso wie das hier ist jetzt beides
eingetragenes hate symbol stellt euch das mal vor also das ist das ist das ist
ist das ist has also wer den zusammenhang zwischen has von so einem
frosch und und einem positiven ok zeichen nicht so sehr erkennt ich erkenne ihn
auch nicht der witz ist ja der witz ist ja dieses ok zeichen ist eigentlich
in ford chant roll ich weiß ich habt ihr euch mal die
geschichte davon durchgelesen die sagen ja alle so nach dem motto dieses ok hand
diese ok hand wäre white power hier so und in wirklich also das da das wäre
white power und wenn man sich das durchliest mal die die die geschichte
von von diesem von diesem ganzen zeug das ist einfach nur der krasseste
ford chant roll nicht aller Zeiten die haben schon viele sachen gemacht das ist
der der der mainstream erfolgreichste ford chant roll so weil das haben dann
irgendwann medien aufgegriffen und haben gesagt hoho white power
ford chant gesagt hat sie wollen das quasi promoten als das wäre das ein
white power symbol und die medien haben das aufgegriffen und seitdem ist halt
diese ok hand white power dabei war das einfach nur von
anfang an ein übelster ford chant roll und jetzt jetzt kann sich das irgendwie
keiner eingestehen dass es einfach nur ein troll war
ich weiß nicht also das ist das ist ja zumindest was ich eigentlich erzählen
wollte ich bin jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen hier ab ja und pepe pepe ist
natürlich auch so ein tanzender frosch wenn das kein hate symbol ist dann weiß
ich auch nicht egal die menschheit und die welt dreht dreht durch also das wollte
ich jetzt sagen genau also bei uns auf der arbeit ist das so nachdem wir ja
viele sachen mittlerweile in gruppa netus laufen haben es war es war bei uns so
wir waren also bis vor ein paar jahren war bei uns das alles zum größten teil
noch relativ klassisch also sprich wir haben ein rechens wir haben mehrere
rechenzentren wir haben leute die sich drum kümmern wir haben relativ viele
server wir haben unser zeug drauf laufen zum größten teil selbst programmiert
das enterprise business banken zeug ja also stonks so die richtig nur die
richtig harten sachen und irgendwann kam es dann auf die idee und da muss man
sagen eine der besten entscheidungen rein rein zukunftsorientiert mäßig denen
so eingefallen in letzter zeit ok wir versuchen jetzt weniger selbst zu
hausen sondern mehr in die cloud zu verlagern
ich dachte eigentlich damit ist gemeint ok wir verlagern das in die cloud sei es
gruppa netus oder sonst wo und kümmern uns da zumindest noch ansatzweise
selbstrum aber nein damit ist unter anderem auch gemeint
irgendwelche externen dienstleister machen das dann was sehr wir es an vielen
stellen weil mittlerweile haben wir irgendwie 36 oder näh näh näh eher 63
verschiedene dienstleiste die jeder irgendwie einen einen einen microservice
oder so für uns bereitstellen keiner blickt mehr genau durch aber was was
das was das beste ist es wurde sich damals überlegt
jetzt wird es bisschen laut gerade oder ne oder ist das nur bei mir so
oh ja das tk ist gut live subscribe dankeschön
exzellent bis bisschen laut ne
ok perfekt so also bin ich wo bin stehen im stans genau so und dass man da den
übert jetzt mal da die übersicht behält hatten sie eigentlich eine ziemlich gute
idee und zwar für jeden microservice der irgendwo eingekauft wird er irgendwie in
in in der cloud gehostet wieder sonst wo wird ein ein übersichts
zusammen so übersichtsdokument erstellt wurde dann drin steht wer ist der
ansprechpartner und wo läuft das ganze und so also eigentlich recht sinnvoll
das problem dabei ist nur ich habe heute mal ein bisschen bisschen diese not
gedrungen diese übersichtsdokumente angeguckt
oder steht jetzt ohne scheiß drin also es gibt so ein es gibt so ein template
was man sich kopieren kann und ich habe nach einem nach einem service gesucht und
ich habe ich dachte ich habe den service gefunden dann gehe ich in das dokument
rein und was sehe ich da da steht bitte hier name der anwendung eintragen
also da stand der beispiel text drinne da hat irgendjemand das template kopiert
und hat einfach nur den titel angepasst also ist ein riesen to do gewesen das
ding ist ergeblich schon drei monaten live und läuft und keiner hat eine
ahnung davon so dann habe ich ein projekt manager
gefragt der da der in irgendwie damit in zusammenhang steht und der meint dann
ja dafür gibt es keinen steckbrief heißt dafür gibt es keinen steckbrief
habe ich zu ihm gemeint sehe ich denke es muss doch für jedes produkt was
irgendwo läuft muss es doch angeblich einen steckbrief geben weil wie soll man
das denn sonst wissen wo das ist ja dafür gibt es keinen steckbrief weil
das team was den steckbrief erstellen sollte hat ja 30 mikros es ist kein
witz 30 micro services unter unter ihren fittichen und die sind nicht so
schnell hinterher gekommen steckbriefe zu schreiben als die sachen als wie die
sachen live geschaltet wurden
ok ok oder hat er mir da hat er mir noch versucht zu erklären ja in dem fall ist
es aber noch mal anders nach dem service den ich gesucht habe und zwar den
service den ich gesucht habe dafür wird es auch nie einen steckbrief geben weil
den steckbrief pass auf das ist mega wir und und wahrscheinlich erkennen sich
die ein oder anderen die die in der finanzbranche bei einer bank arbeiten
wieder wenn das wenn das so so kompliziert ist in dem fall wird es
auch gar kein steckbrief und und service mehr geben weil es ist so dass den
steckbrief den ich gefunden habe der eigentlich nur ein beispiel steckbrief
war den habe ich auch nur gefunden weil eine beta version dieses services mal
bei uns in unserem kuppernet das in der cloud gehostet wurde jetzt hat man sich
allerdings dazu entschieden eine neue version bei einem externen
dienstleister programmieren zu lassen der das dann bei einem weiteren externen
dienstleister in einem kuppernet cluster bei einem weiteren externen dienstleister
der übrigens für ganz viele banken auch hosting macht das betrieben wird und
das problem ist jetzt nur die alte version kann auch nicht abgeschaltet
werden weil noch 150 beta user und das sind wichtige wie ip beta user dabei
das noch für ein paar ihrer kunden benutzen das heißt wir haben jetzt zwei
mal den gleichen service der auch gleich heißt nur einmal ist er intern
eigentlich eine beta version bei uns für den gibt es keinen steckbrief weil der
einfach nur template text anhält für den anderen wird es kein steckbrief geben
weil der obwohl es eigentlich steckbrief geben muss für jeden microservice auch
extern gehostet weil der bei einem externen dienstleister programmiert
werden sie bei einem externen dienstleister hosten lässt in der cloud
alles klar oder jetzt ist jetzt ist oder ich habe auch gerade alle jetzt ich
dreht alle komplett am rad ich schreibe jetzt das das geile war ich habe dann
zu ihm so auch noch gemeint ja ich okay was schreibe ich jetzt da rein
also wenn man angenommen man soll das jetzt noch mal noch mal bereit stellen
was für aufwände wäre das denn und er hat mehr oder weniger wortwörtlich
gesagt ich soll irgendwas reinschreiben irgendwas also wenn der projekt manager
der dafür zuständig ist sagt schreib irgendwas rein dann fragt man sich warum
gibt es denn überhaupt also stonks bwl projekt manager ist echt eine welt das
wird nie meins sein big brain
aber ihr kennt wahrscheinlich also wer wer bei bisschen größeren unternehmen
arbeitet gerade in der finanzbranche die sind so intern so wir
strukturiert und auf der einen seite old school aber sie wollen modern sein dass
es nicht dass es nicht hinhaut es ist nicht umsonst so dass der die oder der
ich weiß es nicht genau wir wollen ja hier kein irgendwie falsch anreden oder
so sonst ist ja hier gleich monka tos angesagt
it mann der deutschen bank hat ja in dem intervue gesagt die deutsche bank wäre
it mäßig das dysfunctionalste unternehmen was er je gesehen hat oder
sie kann ich mir vorstellen wie gesagt ich ich bin ich bei der deutschen bank
ich kenne bei der deutschen bank gearbeitet haben und da ist es ähnlich
ja bei uns ist auch wir also gerade gerade im finanzsektor die sind die sind die
sind intern extrem old school aber wollen halt irgendwie modern sein und das
ist die kombination ist echt schwer so chat fragt am sonntag habe ich
migration es x zu halber wie am sonntag und sonntag sagt immer dreimal
windowserver und ein debian hast du für den debian eintipp verstehen war ein tip
tipp bezüglich was
da verstehe ich jetzt kann
was es zu beachten gibt
vms umziehen ist doch total einfach ich weiß ich kann hyper wie das vmdk gedürnt
von es x da musst du nichts großartiges beachten im zweifelsfall wenn du die
storage nicht umziehen kannst oder dass das image nicht umziehen kannst einfach
die dehnen fertig aus das wird schon funktionieren das ist recht also vms
umziehen ist meistens relativ unkompliziert ich muss mal kurz die
klima an machen ist übelst warm leute 26 grad
was schweizer post ist etwa gleich skandalös vergeht kein ja und das
millionen hinter hinterzogen werden und das folgen ja aber uns bei uns ist das
bei also wir kriegen das in deutschland schon besser hin bei uns müssen keine
warum warum haben die immer noch ein bild von meinem weinkeller bei uns
müssen keine millionen hinterzogen werden bei uns kostet ja allein schon das
umbauen von einem segelschiff millionen die werden nicht hinterzogen die werden
offiziell ausgegeben ist überhaupt kein problem
die sx tool muss ich ja da runter kriegen die sx tools ganz im paket
managen deinstallieren
naja gut
habt ihr eigentlich mitgekriegt dass segway pleite ist segway pleite mitgekriegt
ich fand die roller immer richtig geil vor allem wenn man irgendwo eine
rundgang gemacht hat oder so was und segway roller gekriegt hat also fände
ich cool aber segways sind leider pleite und spätestens wahrscheinlich seit
elektroroller auch mehr oder weniger überflüssig ja die sind pleite die sind
die sind weg vom fenster
hat jemand einen tipp für eine externe platte nass die automatisch mit
one drive synchronisieren kann ich befürchte dass er nass eigentlich zu
viel du willst du willst du willst quasi in den stand alone gerät was
one drive synchronisieren kann keine ahnung keine ahnung keine ahnung ob es so was gibt ich
mein was immer noch was immer noch geht ist du kannst du kannst da irgendein so
singelbord computer dran machen und sei es nur raspberry pi das limit der
limitierende faktor hier ist ja wahrscheinlich dein upload speed und
nicht die art der au von der festplatte
weiß ich ob die das unterstützen
anscheinend anscheinend können die wd smart things wie heißen die wd keine
ahnung also das habe ich noch nie gedanken drüber gemacht aber sag mal so
wenn du was billiges brauchst kannst ja in raspberry pi 3 die sind ein bisschen
günstiger kaufen und einfach anstöpseln und und was diesen zyn konfigurieren
das ist nicht schwierig aber und fertiges kenne ich nicht nee keine ahnung
oh ich muss übrigens mal ppega board starten fällt mir gerade auf ich habe
bestimmt schon wieder zig questions und fragen und soll ich übersehen ja
sebaro er will ja kein nass wenn ein fertiges nass kauft wie in zynology dann
kann es das dünken da wollte irgendwas was quasi mehr oder
weniger nur eine externe platte ist aber da fällt mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nix
eine das ppega board brauchen wir in in dunkel auf jeden fall ist viel viel
besser warum ist das ppega board hier nicht
dunkel kann mir das mal einer erklären dark reader chrome ist das überhaupt ein
chrome das chrome hinzufügen add ah yes sehr gut jetzt ist das ppega board auch
dunkel jetzt ist alles gut was woran kann es liegen dass beim klonen eines
raspberry pi images die mecha adresse auch mit geklont wird weil die ach so
hä das sollte eigentlich nicht mit geklont werden
wüsste nicht wo da irgendwo in der konfig eine mecha adresse drin steht
also mecha adresse von was von deinem von deinem von deinem netzwerk interface
das wäre sehr merkwürdig wenn die mit geklont wird dass du irgendwelche
internen bridge interfaces die da anlegt dass die mit geklont werden ok das
verstehe ich
der blog watcher sagt segway ist ein parade beispiel patente gekauft von
china bis sie von den chinesen übernommen wurden sind sie weil sie
nicht habe ich nicht habe ich nicht verfolgt hast du schon mal berührung mit
automotiv software entwicklung gehabt nö sagt sagt mir gar nix
auf twitch
ne anscheinend nicht so das war mein jetzt was mir gerade einfällt wisst ihr was ich
schon eine weile mal wieder ausprobieren wollte bei welcher version sind die
eigentlich bei zabbix jetzt ist reveal so sehe ich gerade aus bei mir im stuhl
ach guck mal die sind bei 5 auch das probieren wir auch mal aus das probieren
wir mal aus stream in den zabbix 5 die wollte ich nämlich schon bestimmt
eine halbe also seit anfang des jahres wollte ich den mal wieder ausprobieren
haben die vielleicht ordentliche what's new 5 what's new what's new ok zeit mal
her out of box integration rws azure digital ok ja das die sammel singles
ein ja gut ok supports htp webhooks blacklist
hier das ist nichts wirklich spannendes dabei ein secret store ok das ist ganz
nützlich
seit version 4 haben in der timescale db dabei das habe ich gesehen
timeseries support es gibt neuen zabbix agent ok
monitoring that is easy to use also eins muss man muss man dazu zabbix mal sagen
sieht das in irgendeiner art und weise easy to manage aus also wenn zabbix eine
sache nicht ist dann easy to manage also das frontend ist also also so war es von
wir
ich finde es aber cool das muss man den echt mal lassen dass die nicht so den
kopf in den sand stecken und sagt den sagt dem motto wir supporten jetzt quasi
so die alte welt bis es bis es die nicht mehr gibt also irgendwas was selbst
gehostet wir sonst was die gehen schon mit der zeit und vielleicht schaffen
sie es auch wieder dass man sagen kann ok wir benutzen zabbix als mehr oder
weniger einzige monitoring lösung dass man dann prometors wegschmeißen kann man
kann kein kraft an mehr brauche sondern mit zabbix grafen wir alles schön
machen kann
jmx counter das ist java krepp
haben wir hier neues ok die status seite sieht immer noch genauso hässlich aus
wie zabbix zwei zeiten was ist das it service management oder was ist it sm
it service service management
alerting systems teams was leck okay das probieren wir mal aus in einem der
nächsten streams ich wollte schon wie gesagt lange mal wieder neue zabbix
version ausprobieren ob die jetzt taugt weil so ganz glücklich bin ich hier mit
meinem grafana setup nicht ich meine für die heizung ist das ja cool für die
heizung ist mein grafana prometors setup ja gut allerdings machen wir hier weg
allerdings für für reine so so klassische monitoring geschichten mit
server ist nicht da dienst ist nicht da da ist so ist mir so ein zabbix lieber
aber wenn ich das ganze zeug alles mit zabbix abfackeln könnte bei mir daheim
wäre ich auf rot rüber weil da brauche ich dann zwei sachen weniger
naja
was moment das ist nicht von heute oder
das ist das ist vom letzten stream muss man löschen
das blicke ich dann immer durch
hast du heute was besonderes vor ich hätte eventuell was für dich was denn
schieß mal los ich bin ehrlich gesagt nur online gekommen weil ich heute
relativ gut drauf bin und ich weiß auch woran das liegt leute weil ich heute
morgen eine stunde sport gemacht habe und heute nachmittag noch mal eine stunde
sport gemacht habe also ich meine das meiste ich weiß
soll wir sagen das ist das ist kein sport wenn man sich einfach ein bisschen bewegt
also ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie krass die gewichte gehoben oder bin hier
wild rum gerannt aber zweimal eine stunde relativ zackig bewegt ist für mich
schon anstrengend
wann kommt ein fitness und lifestyle kanal ich mache kein fitness und
lifestyle kanal ich mache was ich mache whatsapp gruppe full page os was ist das
der sebaro verschickt links
komm in die gruppe mache ich raspberry pi distro to display a full page browser
on boot warum warum weshalb für den dashboard oder so
für den dashboard würde ich gar kein warum nimmst du nicht ein tablet
sie bauen wissen ich tablet also ich habe für meine dashboards billige feier feier hd
tablets ach so weil es tv weil es fernsehen sein
wirst ok ja dann dann
blöd ja wenn es fernseher sein müssen dann ist es nicht schlecht weil mit dem
raspberry pi 4 hast jetzt ja auch ordentliche hdmi output ok dafür ist
nicht schlecht die sache ist nur die wir können das zwar im stream ausprobieren
aber ich glaube das ist fürchterlich langweilig weil man sieht ja nix wir
würden ein image auf der sd karte machen den raspberry booten und dann könnte ich
mit der elgato capture karte sehen wie den browser aufgeht also da da gibt es
ja nicht viel zu sehen frost got live da gibt es ja nicht viel zu sehen
raspberry pi der booten und den browser auf machen die glaube das ist nicht so
spannend hat das ganze job suche gedulds rund weg machen
ja das ist nicht zum testen sondern nur zum image kompilieren
man muss das selbst kompilieren sind die noch bei trost
warum gibt es da nicht einfach einen download what the fuck
ok moment download
moment da muss doch download geben
nightly builds hier oh ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob ich diese das
überhaupt verwenden würde wenn das die offizielle seite ist der hat seine
domain nicht verlängert der hat vergessen seine domain zu verlängern
wie lange geht das eigentlich der hört ja gar nicht mehr auf
da ist er der cute mod auf github seins da verstehe ok also ich habe mal probiert
mit qmo mit qmo raspberry pi sachen zu kompilieren das ist so extrem langsam
das hält im kopf net aus was probierst du dann jetzt halt mal ja
ubuntu 20 04 du willst auf desktop pc kompilieren na
hier das könnte man tatsächlich mal probieren aber aber cross kompilen
am kod mit qmo ist wirklich wirklich extrem langsam also wirklich extrem
langsam
weil weil das ist ja kein cross kompilen das ist quasi am emulieren und darauf
kompilen bis zum fehler ging es recht schnell ja wahrscheinlich hat er noch
gar nicht richtig angefangen kann man das nicht ohne qmo cross kompilen
vielleicht habe ich noch nichts dazu gefunden wie man das ordentlich macht ich
habe das mal probiert für open cl das ist so ein image processing ding das habe
ich auch versucht cross zu kompilen und das habe ich nicht hinbekommen dann habe
ich mit qmo versucht zu kompilen und das war so extrem langsam also extrem
extrem langsam also quasi für für einen kompil schritt 15 minuten und so was
ja richtig massif langsam vielleicht habe ich auch irgendwas verkehrt gemacht
nicht auszuschließen
so gibt es ist in der it welt irgendwas spannendes passiert heute polnische
gesicht sind okay das verfahren was die chinesen machen sägwer ist pleite
verbessern mich überhaupt net neues teleskop
also für effizienten die das habe ich früher verwendet
mit der apotheise plus okay keine keine alles nur ultra langweilige it news
heute an golem was hat hacker news irgendwas spannendes
auch mal mit exagier probiert ich weiß gar nicht was exagier ist was ist
exagier exagier
windows emulator
was ist das
android android emulator ne sagt mir gar nix
hast du die 100 terabyte ssd gesehen nein echt wo excellent 100 terabyte
ist aber schön klein das ist ja ein schnapper 40.000
ist ja fast geschenkt
aber 40.000 dollar ssd ist schon nicht ohne
so ist hier irgendwas tolles passiert heute
tiktok app ist no longer permitted on mobile devices dann excess amazon mail
ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal
ja das gab es 2011 schon das kenne ich das habe ich damals sogar verwendet
libra office
moment moment wo habe ich es wo habe ich ja libra office schlimm alles ist ja
das allerschlimmste es ist heute nix passiert das ist ja mal mega langweilig
microsoft support auf pvp und windows
u fucking chaos
oh pvp ist nicht länger supported auf windows
das sind wir aber traurig
also nix gegen pvp
ehrlich gesagt nur die sache ist warum sollte man das auch also in der
heutigen zeit warum warum unter windows da würde ich im leben nicht auf die idee
kommen das unter windows laufen zu lassen
rast auf esp 32 gibt es da was neues das letzte mal wo ich geguckt habe war das
kaum zu benutzen
a web based version of windows xp ms paint
btf
das funkt aber
aber man also
also leute
das windows xp paint hatte so kein
smooth smoothing oder
ja kommt mal
das funktioniert das das ist wieder in den web
bullshit
dass es nicht pixelgenau ist guckt euch das mal an
ich setze jetzt hier ab
bäm und es wird fetter
das ist wieder so typischer
web bullshit
den du mit ordentlich native anwendung in dem form nicht hast
wie ging das jetzt noch mal wo kommt man hier ausfüllen so ne
excellent
und jetzt hier
ganz fett
zack in lila
in gelb in gelb
und wie macht man die schriftart
poggers
mein neuer kanal hintergrund so sieht es aus
wir brauchen auch die schrift hier
die brauchen eine schrift die vom browser support wird ok
x
was ist das
moment der konnte keine transparenten schriften sich das richtig
boah ist das schlecht
und dass das hinter dem ist das ist verpackt
guck mal das ist verpackt als fack
ach nee moment das ist nicht verpackt das ist das macht ja alles in einer ebene
das ist ja nicht und das sind ja nicht
das ist ja nicht dass das unterschiedliche ebene können das ist
nicht verpackt das ist tatsächlich so gewesen
ok
wunderschön
ist das nicht toll
und braucht wahrscheinlich
20 mal so viel ram und cpu wie unter windows xp
das ist echt wenig passiert heute total langweiliges zeug nur
übelst langweilig
oh flutter von linux ok
das ist cool
jetzt doch mal langsam zeit eine runde flutter auszuprobieren
ok also dann muss man sich dann müssen wir mal die üblichen sachen mal
abchecken ob flutter auf dem desktop mittlerweile flutter desktop hat das
ding mittlerweile in den webview eingebaut
flutter desktop webview plugin
wer nicht ist es useless
nein auch nicht super
ich brauch kein ui framework was keine aktuellen webinhalte nicht in irgendeiner
art und weise einbinden kann
also es gibt zwei sachen zumindest ist das so mein check um zu gucken wie gut
also was man alles mit einem
desktop ui framework machen kann
also so an sonderfällen das erste was es haben muss ist in ordentlichen webview
ohne geht nichts in der heutigen zeit du musst so oft mal irgendwelche html
content sachen anzeigen auch in stink normalen apps und sei es nur dass du eine
hilfe haben willst oder oder keine ahnung ne login irgendwas webview brauchst du
heutzutage kommst nicht dran vorbei
und das zweite ist gibt es die möglichkeit open gl oder unter windows
direkt x inhalte einzubinden wenn beides gegeben ist dann dann dann besteht die
chance dass das ui framework was taugt
gucken was habe ich im chat was übersehen habe
moment wo muss ich denn da ppega bord
ich miete mir mal eben ein klaut abends auf und schaue ob es darauf komplett
weg geht ja macht das mal wie gesagt hetzner klaut hetzner klaut digital
außenkaufs da 6 90 kerne 180 g ram bäm für 50 cent
gab es dazu was neues hier banana wave sobald es nämlich funktioniert bin ich
der erste der den kram ausprobiert
das hat das letzte mal nämlich nicht gut nicht nicht gut funktioniert
beziehungsweise was ich gelesen habe drüber war ein bisschen unfertig
so wir haben eine englische frage im chat
hi i want to learn about data structures and algorithms so which is the best
language i would say best for starters to learn is its python because there are a
lot of tutorials how tos beginner guides lot of what's webcasts youtube videos and
it's heavily used in universities to max nein warum nicht warum nicht heißen ich
würde doch zum einstieg ist heißen wunderbar erstmal die welches mit seh
keine welches mit seh heißen ist zum einstieg wunderbar
also ich warte bis das bis das schöner zu nutzen ist was richtig cool werden
wenn plattform i integration machen würde mit esp 32 rust das wäre huge
machen sie wahrscheinlich nicht
deswegen leider muss ich dann noch ein bisschen bei c++ hängen bleiben was
microcontroller angeht auch wenn es mich jedes mal ultra abfakt und wie oft wie ich
habe schon so oft gesagt dass ich c++ für die schlimmste sprache von allen halte
aber ich komme nicht drumherum
yes german language so
vielleicht soll ich mal auf german setzen habe ich nicht das habe ich nicht
german doch habe ich doch steht auch drin deutsch
so also flatter probiere ich aus sobald es auf dem desktop einen ordentlichen
webview gibt ich finde den ui framework ohne webview ist heutzutage nicht
geeignet auf dem desktop übrigens können wir euch auch daran erinnern wo
wir wenn ui 3 brifu was 2 ausprobiert haben vor oder oder oder eins oder so ich
weiß gar nicht mal was das war haben wir ausprobiert letztens im stream vor ist
browser kein webview wenn ein webview ist quasi in den browser im bettet in
da an beide in der anwendung wenn man so wird also quasi so wieder so wie steam
das macht oder wie oder oder im prinzip wie elektron das macht nur dass elektron
halt mehr oder weniger halt fast nur ein browser ist aber ohne webview ohne
webinhalte anzeigen zu können ist ein aktuelles desktop framework finde ich
auch unbrauchbar
was welcher browser war der browser mit den wm pro tab hä
weiß jetzt kann ich was du meinst
zumindest also als wir das hier ausprobiert haben da habe ich ja auf
github rumgeflämt und ich habe jetzt gelesen sie wollen auch deployments
unterstützen ohne dass man diesen ganzen zertifikat scheiß braucht weil das hat
mich so aufgeregt die haben was richtig gutes an start gebracht hiermit für
für windows ui entwicklung endlich mal nach 20 jahren mal wieder was
gescheites neues oder 15 jahren was wpf gehen ja mein wegen auch wieso magst du
eigentlich kein c marks ich mag c ich mag kein c++ ich hasse c++ plus so ein
krampf und wie gesagt haben wir was richtig gutes an start gebracht aber es
funktioniert trotzdem nicht richtig weil du immer noch uwp scheiß brauchst und
immer noch zertifikats kamen und das wollen sie angeblich mit einem der
nächsten previews ausschalten da bin ich mal gespannt
und warum ich kein c++ mag ich weiß nicht ob ich wieder davon anfangen soll
weil ich muss in so gefühlt jedem zweiten stream mich über c++ auslassen
weil die leute fragen ich weiß ich ob es war wieder auch so wieder zeit dafür
wird leute soll ich zipp soll ich den c++ renn starten oder heute nicht
kommt drauf an so wo habe ich denn meinen hau raus
schau wieder es nimmt dann immer kein ende wenn ich anfangen warum c++ kacke
ist gibt es nicht ein klipp bestimmt das ist das ist mittlerweile echt schon die
trigger frage ausrufe zeichnen cpp man sollte mal man sollte mal echt
den clip machen ja welche schrift hast du in deiner manjaro kiste installiert
meinst du das hier das ist hack und im chrome und so ich glaube die weiß ich
gar nicht jetzt was habe ich denn für fonds zeit mal
achso ich bin in der falschen form was habe ich denn da installiert
weiß gar nicht wie man sich nur install anzeigen lassen kann also hier was
haben wir installiert source code fro ich glaube das hier sind die ich glaube
das sind die die man braucht dass es ganz gut aussieht im browser
ansonsten für konsole hack habe ich hier hack regular 16
aber c++ hat auch so eine schöne sind auch ja c++ sind exzellent vor allem so
was hier ich zeige euch mal ein beispiel vor allem sowas hier ist wirklich
absolut exzellent so was ja ist das ist das schön ja ich glaube in keiner
sprache sieht es schöner aus als in c++
dass ich vor allem diese zeile finde ich wunderbar diese zeile die ist so ach die
ist so toll sowas gibt es nur in c++ mark ldmm vier monate dankeschön
exzellent big brain subscription also ich finde pysen hässlich als c++
ja jeder wie er will ja sage ich kann kann jeder verwenden was im wasser mark
was waren noch mal die drei punkte in c++ das ist in den list list initializer
oder sowas oder so irgendwie glaube ich bin mir da gar nicht so ganz sicher
ehrlich gesagt jetzt was es überhaupt macht das plittet irgendwas in listen
aufglauben frage ich so ne setzunter ne moment fuck ich habe vergessen wie man
in wim language setzt ich verwende zu wenig wim in letzter
zeit natürlich alles klar wim logik ne sowas hier setzsynntax html war das
setzsynntax cpp c++ highlighting
das ist wirklich der teufel
ne gehen wir fahrt web view plugin doesn't exist
flock also ich hoffe ja dass flatter sich auch auf dem desktop durchsetzen würde
weil flatter ist das erste desktop ui framework was indem ich neben cute
wirklich potential sehe vor allem weil auch eine große firma dahinter ist und
weil es halt auch mal nicht c++ ist cute ist wunderbar aber es ist halt leider
c++ ich weiß man kann ein bisschen peißen was programmieren aber es ist im
kern hat einfach hardcore c++ und da ist dat doch schon deutlich angenehmer als
c++ und cute auf mobile habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wie gut das
funktioniert aber ich könnte mir vorstellen gerade im mobile bereich ist
es mit flatter einfach um welten besser
wir brauchen eine programmiersprache gibt es bestimmt schon programming
language gemeins immerhin programming language emoji only gibt es bestimmt
schon emoji code siehste ich sag sollte wenn
ihr auf so eine idee kommt man kann immer davon ausgehen das gibt es schon
emoji code open source full blown programming language consisting of
emojis aha das würde ich sagen muss man in einem
nächsten streams mal angucken emoji code das tut schon weh
compile und run your first program basic structure
example ok ok das ist quasi eine funktion oder so man kann sich das leben
auch schwer machen ja das ist quasi eine funktion mit dem namen kirsche oder was
ist das hier blaubeere oder kanada was ist das für
emoji überhaupt grapes ja war ein weintraum traum ach du große scheiße
das ist ein switch oder sowas
es sieht schon hässlich aus muss man sagen
also gut lesbar ist es nicht aber das sind ja die ganzen programmiersprachen
die für sowas erstellt werden nicht man kann emoji code sogar von c und c plus
plus auskollen exzellent das heißt wenn man es von go
kalt ist es schon mal extrem langsam weil go und c interop immer noch sachen
weiß ich auch nicht was damit google los ist interessant das punkt mag ich mir
mal dass das das probieren wir mal aus in einem der nächsten streams das
bestimmt ganz lustig zwar für für eine stunde oder zwei viel länger können wir
damit auch nichts nix machen emoji code
lieber ins chef koden meinst du die programmiersprache chef oder das
automatisierungs infrastruktur es kaut wie man das so schön nennt heute tool
chef
da sind noch buchstaben drin weil das hier wahrscheinlich ein string ist das
hier dürfte sowas sein wie anfangen striche oben anfangen striche oben also
das da das da ist wohl das string in cats simulator
ich warte doch bis es den ersten cross compiler java zu emoji code gibt oder
javascript zu emoji code das gibt bestimmt schon so gestörte sachen gibt
immer als erstes und im zweifelsfall in javascript
ja
muss ich mal ausprobieren was welcher browser war damit mit den
wm pro tab was weiß ich was du meinst du hast heute einen 17.000 euro reifen
gesehen und hast du bestellt
worauf würdest du pf sens drauf machen läuft er nicht auf dem raspberry pie
gibt es kein pf sens für arm
gibt es das nicht der gibt es tatsächlich nicht interessant
hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht
ja also wenn es ein pf sens sein muss dann ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
ich mache alles mittlerweile auf meinem mikrotik router ich hatte früher auch noch
zusätzlichen pf sens aber für die naja handvoll firewall regeln sind es nicht
aber für die 20 30 firewall regeln die ich hab dies mache ich alles auf meinem
mikrotik router mittlerweile und das kann nahezu auch alles was pf sens kann
vielleicht vielleicht nicht so schön und manchen bereichen auch auch vielleicht
gar nicht aber so das was man im heimbereich braucht reicht das open
sens pf sens ja open sens ist ein pf sens ford den seit ein paar jahren gibt
weil sie sich nicht einig waren
ja
wie es gibt pf sens doch ach so und arm auf auf eigener hardware verstehe
das schöne an open sens ist dass du wire guard und so was per plug in nach installieren
kannst das stimmt dns blocken kann der mikrotik router nicht aber wenn ich das
wirklich haben will würde ich dann halt ein meiner raspberry pies zu missbrauchen
dort in den p hol oder irgendwie sowas drauf zu basteln
naja also ich habe zumindest keine verwendung ist großartig dafür jetzt
gehabt
deswegen habe ich meinen pf sens wieder runter geschmissen
brauche etwas das mehrere internet up links ordentlich unterstützt wie willst
du die verwenden load balancing mäßig
irgendwie gekoppelt gibt ja verschiedene arten wie man mehrere internet leitungen
koppeln kann was du kannst dir pf sens theoretisch für
arm selber ja gut man kann viel aber muss nicht unbedingt also das würde ich
mir nicht geben pf sens da kriegst du auch keine automatischen updates und
müsstest permanent selbst an deine updates kombinieren sowas das würde ich
nicht machen
ist das so hell github github gleich viel besser worauf also es hat man schon
gut haben wir das jetzt schon fertig durchguckt apollo 11 kommt was
quantum was kann man nicht aussprechen ja alles klar ok warum hat das projekt
1,3000 also warum hat das so viele github sterne was ist das irgendwas was
der typ gelöscht hat weil weil anzeige war raus oder wie aber schön dass es eine
historien gibt gibt
die sind so viele ey es ist krass wie viele chinesische projekte mittlerweile
auf github sind heftig oder das ist ja fast alles nur chinesisch und fast
alles ja war tencent irgendwas von tencent tnn ist tnn nicht der türkische
fernsehsender den es früher gab tnn
das ist diesen all den uralt also diesen einen der ersten türkischen
fernsehsender die es in deutschland gab weil ich es nicht auch tnn gpt 2
ok also entweder als proxy der über die internaut balanzen ja das mit surfer den
tunnen kombinierten endpoint brauchte dafür auf jeden fall anders funktioniert
das nicht sonst ohne ohne endpoint kannste kannste eh nur das da machen ja
da ist glaube ich da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher ob mikrotik das kann
wahrscheinlich können die sowas aber das ist bestimmt ein bisschen komplizierter
kann die bestimmt ja aber das ist das ist mit opensense oder pf sens bestimmt
einfacher also ich hatte es ja mit zwei uplink so bei pf sens ich hatte es als
backup also sprich bei mir ist die telekom leitung immer angegangen wenn
unity media nicht verfügbar waren umgedreht und was ich auch gemacht hatte
ich hatte ein paar sachen immer über die telekom geroutet und manche sachen
immer über unity media weil es bei schwach sind manche sachen immer über
die telekom geroutet und nicht bei unity media weil manche sachen damals halt
ultra lahm waren über unity media das war ganz praktisch da nehme ich zwei
als ich noch als ich noch zwei internetanschlüsse parallel hatte aber
habe ich ja nicht mehr war mir zu teuer bin jetzt als eigentlich um was geht es
da steht auch im titel keck weh es ist service
ne gehen um nichts besonderes am wochenende machen wir mit einem stream wo
wir dann auch was geht wo dann auch irgendwas los ist muss man mal gucken
welches der themen wir uns da schnappen wir haben jetzt ja einige sachen heute
auch schon dazu aufgeschrieben
also ich bin dazu geneigt mal einen neuen sub x version auszuprobieren
was geht denn jetzt auf einmal was mit der musik los
ich bin dazu geneigt mal die neue sub x version auszuprobieren weil das
interessiert mich auch für mich für mich daheim
wie findest du das studieprojekt safe ist das safe
sieht safe aus es ist eine view js app das ist erst was mir auffällt
das ist das stand hat das stand an für js logo oben drinnen monka wie wie das
wieso ist das lau ding sieht ein bisschen oldschool aus aber ist doch ok
bei was du machen kannst in view js du kannst das hier machen
view cloak du kannst dir dann main tag das da setzen und dann lädt es die
anwendung erst wenn alles andere geladen ist das dann dann taucht dieser ganze
kram im hintergrund nicht auf während das während es lädt so was shop
pokémons ok was genau sollte eigentlich ach das ist auto jazz das ist pokémon
auto jazz eigentlich eine ziemlich coole idee da ganz ehrlich nintendo bevor ihr
einen pokémon moba macht macht auch lieber den pokémon auto battler
ich finde es ist eine coole idee ach so man kann erst eins
ich finde es ist eine coole idee den pokémon auto battler zu machen
sollte jetzt nicht eigentlich was auswählen können es ist doof dass es
hier übereinander geht dass man da nicht richtig tracken droppen kann so sollte
ich nicht eigentlich eigentlich was kaufen kann
du was ja ist bagi du musst die an den start ziehen
ah ich finde es eine gute idee ich finde es ist eine gute idee
leider ist er problematisch nintendo eigentum zu verwenden im uni projekt jetzt
vielleicht nicht aber generell da jetzt irgendwie vielleicht in den free game
draus zu machen ist ja das problem nintendo band ja alles weg was was
irgendwas von ihnen verwendet vielleicht erinnert sich noch jemand an pokémon
uranium das ist ja so in so einem rpg maker mod gewesen wo einer jahre lang
dran rum gebastelt hat wo die leute damals gesagt haben macht mehr spaß als
die aktuellen offiziellen pokémon spiele und nintendo gleich erstmal
gebannt juckt uns nicht
aber ich glaube einen browser basierten guten browser basierten auto battler
weiß ich nicht ob es da schon was gibt das wäre vielleicht tatsächlich was
wo man ein cooles free game machen könnte
aber die idee finde ich gut
ich der auto battler trend ist ja auch schon wieder vorbei
guck mal gucken wir mal gucken wie viel views das hat
ach nee nee nee nee nicht autochess guck mal autochess wie ist der kram jetzt
es heißt ja nicht mal autochess wie heißt da wie heißt der kram jetzt der
der lol auto battler teamfight tactics teamfight tactics
das ist ein richtig guter starcraft spieler spiel jetzt auto battler
ok das spiel noch ein paar wie es aussieht das gucken auf 15k oder es geht
doch halbwegs was mich ja echt überrascht hat auf twitch ist mal gucken
ob das heute immer noch so ist ja dota anderlord spielt keiner mehr
das ist dead dead as fuck
ich glaube die haben die haben auch schon instant support aufgegeben wieder
welf ist ja bekannt dafür game rauszubringen games rauszubringen und
irgendwie instant support einzustellen war bei bei architekt ist das oder ja das
gleiche was mich überrascht hat dass ich das tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen auf
twitch gehalten hat ist ok es ist schon wieder weg ist schon wieder weg das
ubisoft moba nicht moba das ubisoft
bettel royal halber irgendwas mit halber wie ist das halber halber halber halber
halber halber wie ist das nicht apex halber
warte minute wo ist es denn wo ist es denn moment ein paar ein paar scape da ist es doch ein
kvr das ist komplett abgeschissen
das ist komplett abgeschissen ist noch klaus beta war valorant auch und
valorant hatte das drop system und es haben so extrem viele geguckt mehr als bei
release also sofern man beta codes droppen
kann jaja wahrscheinlich ansonsten ist aber es ist wenig es ist wirklich wenig
die ersten paar tage deswegen hat mich das nämlich überrascht die ersten paar
tage hatte das glaube ich 43.000 views und so was und jetzt ist weg aber gucken
mal gucken guck mal wo bloß wird empfohlen
guck mal da ist hier stehe ich direkt nicht auf totaler blech aber immerhin
beide beide haben wir auf twitch dreistellige dreistellige viewer zahlen
nur dass er halt noch 1000 dazwischen hat was mich aber persönlich echt
überrascht hat das da jetzt nicht vom spiel her ich dachte ja als valorant in
der beta war dass der hype den das spiel hatte gerade wegen den loot boxen auf
oft also dass man kies droppen konnte dass das halt total over hyped ist ins
geheim habe ich mir damals schon gedacht dass das spiel wahnsinnig potential
hat man hat auch gesehen es sind so viele tier 2 tier 3
sehr cs spieler da jetzt am start teilweise auch tier 1 leute die da
spielen nebenbei es sind ehemalige overwatch pros am start also durch die
bank weg alle möglichen sachen und man sieht das game hat echt hat hat echt eine
zukunft ja wenn man sich das anschaut dass du hier spieler hast
ich mein simpel kennt man heiko kennt man den kenne ich nicht den kenne ich auch
nicht ok doch nicht alle aber sind sind einige richtig gute cs spieler dabei
das sieht das sieht ja nicht aus wie valorant ja ja ne aber finde ich nice ja
finde ich echt nice es ist kein spiel für mich ich mag so rumgestellt
ja das ist ja kein schleichspiel in sich aber ihr wisst was ich meine ja ich will
eher so was wie battlefield in your face haben aber das finde ich gut ich guck es
mir sehr gerne an aber selbstspielen ist nicht so meins
nun ja die sache ist ja auch die mit valorant da steht halt eine große firma
dahinter die auch bekannt dafür ist dass sie e-sports mäßig in letzten jahren
ein bisschen was auf die reihe gekriegt habe ja ich weiß es gibt auch einiges
einige kritik an dieser loll pro league oder wie heißt die lcs
ne ist das lcs quasi die offer watch league von loll nur dass die halt
besser organisiert ist als die offer watch die offer watch ist so im arsch
was hat ein twitch offer watch was wie läuft es da grad so die haben auch glück
dass in park große feste streamer haben offer watch league hat sich ja verpisst
zu youtube was halt mega fail ist die youtube offer watch league hat bestimmt
keine view zahlen zeig mal her
ok ok mal die wort aufrufe angucken
ja das sind die views über den gesamten broadcast
loll das ist so schlecht so schlecht die view zahlen sind einfach nur voll im arsch
bei offer watch aber zurecht ich meine wer will e-sport auf youtube gucken das
ist ja fast so wie wenn man wie wenn man facebook gaming gucken würde oder so
habt ihr gesehen ninja ist jetzt auf youtube
noch mal easy 30 millionen so geht es so muss es machen
man kommt dein zweistelliger millionenvertrag ja ist schon grad beim
anwalt was sagst du noch mal in einem deiner videos die größten hater sind
oft die größten fans sage ich glaube ich die größten hater sind oft die
größten fans habe ich da ab und zu schon mal gesagt was hier auch einfach true
lul weh ist guckt euch an die hardcore flamer auf auf reddit offiziellen
forren und sonst was egal bei welchen spiel das sind die die leute das sind
also die die da am lautesten am längsten und am lautesten rumflamen sind
die das spiel 15 stunden am tag durchspielen ist in jedem game so die
leute die seit die seit zehn jahren im offiziellen vorm am start sind und dort
sagen wocheiß spiel blizzard sagt dass ich heiße dass ich heiße neue patch ist
wieder scheiße wieder scheiße wird immer schlechter das spiel sagt einfach nur
noch warum spiele ich das überhaupt noch nie noch ein patch und schon wieder
schlechter gemacht blizzard what are you doing
das sind die die zehn jahre dauer subscribes sind zu wo und jedes a down
holen sie es halten
gut ich weiß ich ob es auf programmier sprachen zutrifft ich benutze c++ ja
nur wenn es unbedingt sein muss
ok sie brauchen ja dann ist es nice
es gibt ja heutzutage noch genug leute die ernsthaft behaupten wollte
vorkauf hat mmo's erfunden ja und das ohne ohne einen witz machen zu wollen die
das ernst meinen
der wao ist das beste beispiel für aber overwatch ist auch so du hast welche
die für sinford seit anfang an am start flamen seit anfang an rum und kaufen
täglich skins
es ist also ausnahmen bestätigen die regel also nicht alle den spiel
heiten sind jetzt übelste fanboys den spiel ist den ganzen tag ich kann auch
overwatch heiten und habe also gar nicht mal auf erwacht an sich sondern wie
blitzer damit umgeht und auch wie sie das weiterentwickeln und welche
richtung das game gegangen ist und geht ohne es zu spielen ich spiele es überhaupt
nicht also ich kann mir ich kann mir auch war schon eine ganze weite nicht mehr
geben
max muss heimlich overwatch ne ich habe die letzten tage fast nur perso
weg sei gespielt half life 3 soll zum teil prozente
also wenn wir irgendwann auch mal ein half life 3 sehen dann weiß ich mir einen
kleinen fuß zähl
ja was interessiert mich 2013 die pläne sind doch eh schon komplett über
haufen geschmissen
ja also da habe ich meine zweifel dass in nächster zeit nach live 3 auch nur auch
nur erwähnt wird von welfer er kann es ja nicht mehr hören 5.000 euro für ein
vr headset ist schon ordentlich hätte ich mir natürlich hätte man zu 5.000
euro vor er hätte man sofort gekauft alex alex ist nicht half life 3
es ist die haben ja sogar interviews geführt wo die gesagt haben dass
während der entwicklung mal kurz überlegt wurde es nicht half life 3 zu
nennen allerdings wollten sie die entwickler und
dem ganzen nicht so einen druck aussetzen
außerdem ist es ja auch nicht wirklich eine fortsetzung erstens wo ist gordon
freeman und zweitens warum spielt 3 4 4 2 das hat keinen sinn also ich hoffe ja
immer noch ihr wisst dass ich alter half life fanboy bin ich hoffe ja immer noch
drauf dass irgendwann mal den half life 3 rauskommt 8 kern x86 prozessor aus
china ok 16 nanometer da freut sich intel bestimmt in intel kennt sich mit
so mit so fertigungsgrößen aus
fahrach fazit ist das
unter dem eines aktuellen atom
ok also nicht sonderlich geil aber die chinesen haben wir sowas keine
probleme die in 15 jahren haben die haben die auch stelle cpus die haben
wir da überhaupt keine schmerzen mit wenn es da was gibt was sie reverse
engineern können machen die das moin der akte
hast du linux oder windows in einer vm linux das ist meine vm das ist meine
vm und das hier ist ein desktop drauf ja ich du hast recht erkennt man jetzt nicht
unbedingt auf den ersten blick ja es wird einfach nur geswitcht dazwischen
clarity sehe ich genauso das ist auch der grund warum die überhaupt nicht in
zugzwang sind also steam ist auch der grund warum die überhaupt nicht irgendwie
unter unter zugzwang stehen wer öfters die was machen müssen aber alle
allerdings muss man sagen was sie in letzter zeit an games gemacht haben war
bis auf alex nicht so der wahnsinn ich meine ihr heartstone verschnitt hat
gefällt wie sau dota underlords hat es auch hinüber
ansonsten haben die einfach nur sehr lang laufende sachen die erfolgreich
sind dota läuft gut cs so gut so cs könnte man sagen vielleicht so gut wie
noch nie vorher und sie haben steam also die schwimmen die schwimmen im geld
gaben ist bestimmt liest
läuft ja nicht läuft euch das seil noch ja doch läuft noch
aber gestern vorbei ich habe nichts gekauft hat ihr habt ihr was gekauft
wahrscheinlich oder die mal die meisten sachen auf steam sind halt misst es
gibt auf steam zwar so viele games wie nie zuvor so und auch so viele neue games
wie nie zuvor aber es ist so mega viel scheiße dabei auf steam
sommer seil ist an ist vorbei
der gaunter was macht der dann da
ach das ist für die dequan stand alone variante der gaunter gefahr
taugt das das stand alone quent
ein indikator für wie gut sachen läuft ist schauen wir auf twitch spielen leute
ach gibt es das jetzt auch für den pc ane es kommt es kommt nächsten monat für
den pc
mal bitte bettel bei ich gebe lieber nix ein einfach so bei steam man weiß ja
nicht ist eigentlich der chair moment wie heißt der chair der f der chair fucking
simulator mittlerweile raus
das sollte nämlich gestern erscheinen
auf fack ist es wirklich raus
sebaro das ist irgendein image renderer für fristerminal endlich ist der chair
fucking simulator aus excellent reviews
ich gucke in kein dieser posts rein wer weiß was da sache ist
ja scheint er gut zu laufen
das ist ein verarschungs game eindeutig auf den ganzen miss der so auf steam zur
zeit rauskommt der anfang vom ende ich sag es euch der anfang vom ende war der
gold simulator das war der anfang vom ende vom bullshit auf steam genau twitch
ich gucke mal ob das jemals ich gucke mal ob das jemals dient chair
keiner gestreamt
doch hier
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Das ist das ist Reaktion stream
Warum sind Let's Player immer so voll am Eskalieren?
Ja, wie gesagt, der Gold Simulator war der Anfang vom Ende.
Seitdem haben die Leute festgestellt alter mit Mist Games kann man Geld verdienen.
Leute, Chat, ich gehe pennen, bin müde.
Ist alle bereit?
péri
Ist die Pane?
insufficient rausschrauben.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.